al is comparing two recipes for homemade
bread the recipe for white bread calls
for 4/10 of a kilogram of flour the
recipe for whole-wheat bread
calls for 385 thousandth of a kilogram
of flour which bread takes less flour so
the white bread calls for 4/10 of a
kilogram while the recipe for whole
wheat bread calls for 0.385 kilograms or
300 385 thousandths of a kilogram now
the way I wrote it is important you
always want to line up the decimals when
you are comparing because you want to
compare numbers in the same place value
and this is an interesting example of
even though the number down here has
more digits it doesn't mean that it's
necessarily a larger number what we want
to do when we compare numbers and this
is true whether we're dealing with
decimals or not is we start in the
largest place value we could start in
the ones place both of these have zero
ones then we go one place value down we
go to the tenths place the white bread
it requires four tenths of flour while
in the whole-wheat bread we only have
three tenths of flour so we can stop
right there
this has more tense than this does it
doesn't matter that this has more
hundreds and thousands those are less
significant they don't add up to as much
as that as what we're dealing with when
we look just like when we look just at
the tenths place so because 4 is greater
than 3 and we're in the tenths place we
know that white bread takes more flour
we have to be very careful they said
which bread takes less flour so it's
going to be whole-wheat bread three is
less than four let's do another one of
these a group of fifth graders kept
track of the number of hours they spent
working on their science project alright
put the students in order from the least
to greatest amount of time spent the
student with the least amount of time
should be at the top of the list so
pause this video and see if you can do
this and this is actually a screenshot
from the Khan Academy exercise if you're
doing the kind
Kaddi exercise you actually be able to
click on these and move them around
let's compare them so as I mentioned in
the last example when you're comparing
numbers it's good to line up the place
values so let's do that so adam is 5.5
aviv is 5 and jenny is five point one
seven so once again start at the largest
place value start at the ones they all
have exactly five ones so that we move
to the next place value in this case
we're going to go to the tenths place so
when we look at the tenths place
interesting things are going on aviv has
no tents
it's a blank here but you could view
this as five point zero so vivre has the
fewest tenths then comes Jenny with only
one tenth and then Adam has five tenths
so that tells us enough so we can order
the three we don't even have to look at
the hundreds place because the tenths
here are different so the least number
of tenths is Aviv so that's going to be
a vivre is the least they all have the
same number of ones but Aviv's has the
least tenths then comes Jenny Jenny
once again they all have the same number
of ones but then Jenny has less tenth
than Adam and then comes Adam Adam has
the most Adam has the most tense it
doesn't matter that Jenny also has seven
hundredths notice you could do this as
1700s which is going to be less than
five tenths which could also be viewed
as fifty hundredths so the general way
to think about it start at the most
significant the largest place value
compared if things are equal go to the
next place value when things are
different then you have enough
information to start ordering them